they're like okay
if the humans won't
listen to us
or they do listen to us and they
misinterpret us because we're so
different let's just go ahead and be the
human maybe they'll listen to their own
kind so that's when the galactic
federation started to look for
volunteers hey beautiful beings of
higher frequencies do you want to go on
an adventure of a lifetime
it's going to be really fun and it was
really tough to find volunteers from the
galactic federation as you could imagine
why would we leave all of this and go
down there when i reference starseeds it
means that your soul is not originally
from the lower dimensions it's not
originally from planet earth it's
actually from much higher dimensions and
you came to incarnate and volunteer to
be here as a human the problem that
happens what percentage of people are
volunteers then it's hard to say i would
say between 10 to 20 percent
welcome to the pretty intense podcast
i'm danica and i will be your guide
through today's
fascinating conversation get ready to
have your mind absolutely blown mine was
and i've looked into this stuff a lot
today on the show is elizabeth april she
is a past life regressionist she's an
author
she's a truth seeker
and she channels and um one of the big
things that she channels is the galactic
federation and entities in the universe
and so she channels and understands
what's going on information about our
planet interaction with entities it
really goes way back to her dad doing a
past life regression reading for her
when she was young that led into her
doing that that then led into her being
abducted by aliens and it went from
there and that was about 10 years ago i
think so
she's had a decade of
astral projecting into uh different
places in the universe and connecting
with different entities and she's
channeled everything from obviously her
past lives to other people's past lives
where we came from into egypt and
lumeria and atlantis and all kinds of
ancient civilizations we talked about
extraterrestrials we talked about the
different kinds we talked about the role
of
our role on earth we talked about the
the role of and other entities on earth
with us thank you for coming to the
interview thank you for watching please
hit subscribe like this share it comment
are you into this or you're not
i'm really curious and i'm curious if
you've um looked into all this stuff too
and you guys can fill in the gaps too we
can all connect at
we can all we all have the power to
connect with uh other entities and
energies it's just a matter of opening
our minds so
open your mind and enjoy
i know that this episode's not going to
come out today so people aren't going to
be able to hear it but just for
informational purposes well what's going
on now and how do those things affect us
energetically
absolutely um i mean over the past two
to three years there's been a lot going
on as you mentioned human resonance and
um you know just cosmic you know
awakening in general but
right now at this time there's actually
a lot of solar flares that are taking
place and i believe that the sun brings
us a lot of light codes so there's a lot
of upgrades that are taking place with
people and
exhaustion is the number one symptom of
an upgrade not to mention there's also
this huge kind of battle that's taking
place on planet earth at an energetic
level so a lot of people who kind of
just live their everyday
lives uh and and
don't even think about the awakening are
actually in their astral bodies a lot of
the time supporting other people other
places situations or actually in full on
astral battles around the planet so that
could definitely be part of it and then
we have to think about the collective
vibration as well
there's a ton of people who are in a
lower vibrational frequency who are in
fear who are feeling chaotic and that's
going to have a direct impact and effect
on our lives so it could be your best
friend or your family member or a
relationship that's kind of crumbling or
collapsing or just really challenging in
general and that can be also very
draining on the energy um
okay well what's this energetic battle
happening
all right we're doing it um
it's it's kind of a battle between light
and dark and it's happening at a
physical and at a non-physical level
and
essentially we want to come out on the
other end of it on the other side of it
in unity consciousness
and unity really means both light and
dark
living together in harmony so a lot of
people think that like 5d frequency is
this other world this other place this
you know butterflies and rainbows and
aura you know vibrations
and and it is when you're in it but the
way that i kind of like to describe the
fifth dimension frequency is it's a
perception change
and eventually when you change your
mindset and you change your perception
your physical reality will change with
it and it takes a lot longer for that
physical reality to shift into the
highest vibrational alignment because
the physical world is dense as we all
know and it's just a slower vibration so
you may take three years to manifest a
new living situation but to change your
mindset is momentary and so what's
happening on planet earth is the
vibrational frequency the energy on
planet earth is changing it's going from
a very low vibration a very dense
vibration a very linear vibration
and by that i mean it's
all this or all that it's all or nothing
if it's black or white it's right or
wrong that's the linear it's the past or
the future whereas where we're moving is
once again this unified energy this
unified field which is it's yes and no
it's right and wrong it's black and
white it's high and low vibration
and so we enter into this state which is
kind of this quantum simultaneous state
and it can be very overwhelming for
people to enter into a state where
everything exists simultaneously it's
kind of like multitasking but in your
reality
so when we're talking about the
the
energetic battle
being more specific are there like i
feel like i've heard about
if your low vibration is low that it is
like an entry point for entities to be
able to feed off of your energy and when
your energy levels high enough they
can't feed off of you so it's like an
exponential downward spiral
um so
if that's true then what what do you is
that part of the energetic battle
and what is what is trying to take your
energy
yeah so definitely like other entities
um even extraterrestrial beings who are
not of a higher vibration when you're in
a low vibration or you're separated from
that source energy then
um you're very greedy you're very kind
of
individualistic and you're just looking
for power and control and you're hungry
for that and so that's what these
entities gravitate towards they
gravitate towards the light they
gravitate towards the high vibration so
that they can essentially feed off of it
as gross and creepy as that sounds it
actually does happen and there have been
many different
um historical records of
whether it be monsters or entities or
you know nightmarish kind of things
there have been you know records of
these things purported in many different
kind of timelines in human history along
with a religion of course we know you
know the demons and all of that
um and so i truly believe that we can
all kind of go within discern the energy
that is coming in and we can stand in
our power and raise our vibration which
does um shift our our energy away from
the lower vibrations which also like you
mentioned doesn't allow these entities
or energies to hang on to us um so this
basically it's there's a lot of
information with the energetic battle
but
at the end at the end
uh humanity as a whole is meant to make
a decision and the reason why there's a
lot of
extraterrestrial presence around this um
and around planet earth there's a reason
the reason why there's like a lot of
emphasis around this kind of battle at
this time is because we do have to make
a choice whether we're going to continue
this separation continue the darkness
continue the individuality or if we want
to move into that kind of upper
higher vibrational unity and
and and it has huge effects for the rest
of the universe depending on what we
choose
and you know if we're going to go there
i truly believe that human beings are a
hybrid species which means that i
believe that there was a missing link
back in our evolutionary progression and
that missing link was interdimensional
forces and i believe that they came in
and they messed with our dna and they
actually upgraded us with their dna and
because of this we are essentially the
children of these interdimensional
beings and as these children
um what i've channeled is that we are
actually a peace treaty so essentially
what we choose uh based on the certain
vibration that we just embody right it's
a choice but it's also an embodiment
um that will actually have huge effects
on say the galactic federation the solar
system and this galaxy and beyond um
based on the fact that we are presented
with some of the lowest vibrational
energies in the universe and we are
presented with some of the highest
vibrational energies in the universe
and
and we're kind of like these children
like do you want to go to mummy or daddy
you know and like what direction do you
want to go in and that's ultimately our
choice and there's a lot of manipulating
factors that we have to be aware of that
have actually been implanted within
society for quite some time and that's
where you know the distractions and the
fears really come in and that's why we
see a lot of negativity at this time a
lot of polarity at this time
but likewise we see an increasing amount
of awakening souls and higher vibrations
right which is amazing so
why are we so important to
the galactic federation or to the
universe like why do we matter
in this giant universe multiverse where
there's trillions and trillions of
galaxies and
you know even more
zeros on the end to how many inhabitable
planets there probably are why why do we
matter
yeah that was one of my first big
questions when i
uh ended up getting abducted at the age
of 18 and kind of blew the lid off of my
reality of oh my goodness
they do exist they are here
uh why why us like you know i i figured
there's got to be something else out
there but why would they bother with
human beings like this ant like species
you know in the universe this third
dimensional archaic caveman kind of you
know civilization
so
so yeah so that was one of my biggest
questions and once again it comes back
to this peace treaty so from what the
galactic federation has relayed to me
for
many many like millions if not billions
and trillions and beyond years
there has been an energetic battle
happening in the universe and if you
think about it there's all of these
beings all of these civilizations that
are in different dimensions and on
different planets and the ones who are
in higher vibration is let's just all
live in peace and unity together and we
do exist in a binary or polarizing
universe which means that everywhere in
the universe there's going to be light
and dark there's going to be a
difference
which is a really great way to learn and
grow and get challenged and move forward
so the light beings are let's live in
unison uh in harmony with the darkest
aspects of the universe and the lightest
aspects right
and then the darkest aspects or the
darkest civilizations of this universe
are screw that why would i live in
harmony with you and give up part of my
resources when i could just take your
resources
um and and at that kind of logical level
i'm like yeah i guess i could
you know
uh i guess so but that's kind of where
they come from and what the galactic
federation has done and for those who
don't maybe know what the galactic
federation is i always kind of akin it
to
um
uh like a galactic government for the
universe kind of like the un but like
less corrupt maybe a lot less corrupt
and they're just here to align the
different beings in the universe and the
civilizations in the universe to the
universal truth so one of the uh or
universal laws i should say one of the
universal laws
is the law of non-intervention which
basically means that no being is able to
intervene or take the free will away
from another being right so that
sovereignty is so important all
throughout the universe and what happens
in universal galactic history is these
lower vibrational beings continue to
intervene continue to manipulate
continue to take power resources energy
supplies whatever from other
civilizations um which is a huge no-no
in the universe and so the gfl has to
basically come in and like sort things
out and so there's been a lot of peace
treaties and you can think about these
old peace treaties as
kind of like maybe imagining like a
piece of paper like two you know um
officials sit down and say okay like
we're gonna have peace for 10 000 years
i agree to this peace and every single
time the lower vibrational beings always
find a way to get greedy and want more
and override the peace treaty contracts
that is why um a very long time ago it
was prophesized in the galactic
federation from a very ancient mystic
who said there is going to be a
civilization that is created that is
going to end the war of all wars um
and
the and they didn't know what
civilization it was or how it was going
to come to be
but the mystic relayed the information
that this civilization was going to be
the
um the creation of uh once again some of
the lowest vibrational beings and some
of the highest vibrational beings in the
entire universe and us as these children
um with the very extreme polarity within
us the capabilities of really any
experience in the universe we then have
to make a decision but we have to be
free in order to make that choice and
what's taking place right here on planet
earth is all of the old systems that
were created to suppress and oppress us
and to keep us into a lower vibration
they're all crumbling and collapsing
because i believe that a lot of our
societal systems were put in place and
created by some of these lower
vibrational beings
to really trigger us into the fight or
flight to trigger us into the survival
kind of mentality which is the lower
vibration
and so as these systems are crumbling
and breaking down we're feeling more and
more free and more and more liberated
and i know 2020 was a lot for a lot of
people um but i believe that it was
exactly what humanity needed in order to
shift away from
what these norms are you know the nine
to five job you know all of a sudden
people are like maybe i don't want the
nine to five maybe i want to create my
own business maybe i want to have
freedoms in other ways and we're getting
away from the system that was really put
in place for us the galactic federation
gfl that's that's the galactic
federation abbreviation that galactic
federation
of light of light um
how many how many entities or how many
extraterrestrial are in it
and then which one
are we in a contract with hmm good
question yeah so there are like
literally an infinite amount of
different civilizations and species that
are part of the galactic federation any
any being at an individual or collective
level who is just down for unity in the
universe is connected to the galactic
federation and they have contracts with
the galactic federation which are really
just contracts with universal source
consciousness to say you know
i will never uh override someone else's
free will like they're really basic
things you know
um
and so within the structure of the
galactic federation there are all these
different councils and every council has
different beings within them and every
council deals with a different
aspect of the universe or aspect of the
planet it depends there's many different
galactic federation motherships that
kind of all specify in different things
i connect a lot with the galactic
federation mothership that deals with
planet earth which is a pretty big one
because it's a pretty big deal that
we're here and we're going through all
of this
um and one of the councils that i
connect with a lot is the pleiadian
security council is what i call them
there's about eight pleiadian beings and
um the pleiadians look very human um
typically blonde hair blue eyes um
they're much larger though they're like
six to seven feet tall quite broad
shoulders
and yeah they look like this really like
kind of beautiful perfect
race in a sense but that's from our kind
of limited human perception i know some
canadians here on earth yeah oh my god
absolutely and they're just such a joy
to be around
and um
and so they really help with uh security
matters so they've told me about things
like uh a volcano erupting or a giant um
arctic ice shelf breaking off um they've
told me about wars that are coming
they've told me about upgrades that are
happening uh so they're kind of my go-to
uh council to visit and i visit them in
the astral so i
do a lot of astro traveling and remote
viewing i've been doing that for about
10 11 years now probably when i was a
kid too um but consciously doing it for
10 11 years and so i usually go up there
in that sense
um another council that i love
connecting with is the octurian timeline
council it's a smaller council it's
about three to four octarian beings they
are much shorter around five feet
tallest these ones because there's many
different kind of subsets of species
within species um
and they're blue they've got huge
elongated heads and then big uh black
eyes
and they're very lovely like such a joy
and they they a lot of these beings have
a sense of humor so i find myself
laughing a lot i was gonna ask do any of
them have a sense of humor 100 yeah but
a really like awkward sense of humor
like is that a joke like you know
um but you feel their intentions and the
octarian timeline council deals with all
of the different timelines for the
future so that's really fascinating if
you're interested in like simultaneous
time and like quantum physics and i'm
very interested in quant i just
interviewed a physicist yesterday like i
am so interested in quantum physics yeah
and we're as we raise our vibration on
the planet we're getting into this
quantum space like no longer is
classical physics even going to be
relevant to us which is general
relativity that's we were talking about
general relativity relativity and
quantum physics and just einstein
developed general relativity but he also
was a big part of quantum physics and he
didn't really like it and you know
spooky things happening at a distance he
said with quantum entanglement and
everything but but that's essentially
what um
what brian cox said where it basically
is all becoming quantum physics or
quantum mechanics yeah absolutely yeah
and so as far as like human beings being
in contract with the galactic federation
it's kind of like our entire
civilization is connected and in
contracts with
the entire kind of galactic federation
of light um rather than just one being
or one you know council even it's like
we've got a whole
group of beings who are so eager to help
us um but once again because of the law
of non-intervention they're unable to
just
um
assist all of us freely and willingly we
have to ask for help we have to ask for
support and we're getting to a point now
on planet earth where a lot of us are
kind of looking up into the stars and
saying all right if you're out there
like come on down and help us out even
if they're not spiritual or awakened and
i think that's that's incredible we need
more of that
do we
aim our request or
hope for help at any one in particular
or is it oh is it a good enough sort of
statement to just say anybody out in the
universe if you can help us get through
this mess please do you know
yeah exactly so you can aim it
specifically at the galactic federation
just because um they always have our
highest intentions in mind if you're
like hey anyone come down and help it's
kind of like opening up a portal with
the ouija board like you don't wanna you
don't wanna go there but you can
you could always prevent
anything unwanted from coming in by
leaving off all of your intentions um
with the highest good of all involved
and that's what i do hey if anyone could
help us out you know with the highest
good of all involved
yeah i like that when i pull when i pull
cards that's usually what i say like
anyone you know
come in with you know you have my
highest good in mind and loving your
heart like give me you know come through
with an answer i'd love to get back to
all the different extraterrestrial and
entities um what are some of the most
dominant ones um that enter that you
interact with that interact with this
planet um and maybe start there and then
maybe we'll get to some of them that
that don't so much yeah absolutely okay
cool um
and i go through actually the main
species on planet earth or interacting
with planet earth and all of the
physical and vibrational emotional
um similarities that you might have if
you are connected to these species i i
go through all of that in my book so if
we don't get to like every little detail
yeah yeah yeah that's what i recommend
for people to do is your book is called
yeah you're not dying you're just waking
up you're not dying you're just waking
up great yeah yeah which is just it
really sums up the awakening
yeah um
so like i mentioned the pleiadians um
so
so for them if you are connected with
the pleiadians typically you're a very
empathic soul and you're very like every
palladian i've ever met who's incarnated
on planet earth is um
like really all about justice so they're
sometimes they're in a political
background um sometimes they're just
advocates um sometimes they're a part of
non-profits but they're very much so
about justice and integrity and making
sure that everyone is treated fairly and
i love that a lot of pleiadian souls are
also
like very much so like leaders like in
leadership positions um and they'll lead
the way and they're very kind of
charismatic and outgoing in that sense
at a physical level um
some pleiadian
it depends because there's like a
palladian soul which is just kind of
your vibration and then there's a
palladian body so there are two very
different things and that comes from
your ancestral lineage um
you could have been a palladian or an
actuarian or uh anything you could have
been
and you probably have exactly and
because they've intermingled their dna
with our dna there are ancestral lines
so even though i believe we're all
hybrids you could say for example have
uh more pleiadian angelic and maybe
anunnaki dna within you based on your
lineage so for example i believe that
the pleiadians came down to planet earth
originally back in ancient nimeria um
and then they
uh they were very much so populating
ancient atlantis and that's kind of
where their bloodline uh started and
then they started to after atlantis fell
they went all over the world and they
started to intermingle with the uh
indigenous populations and therefore
starting these bloodlines um so yeah so
typically at a physical level a very
symmetrical um very symmetrical body
very symmetrical face and typically like
some palladins i've met have like
stunning blue eyes but that's not always
the case um but like i said just a very
warm soft presence within them
leadership and a lot of like that the
fight for justice
um then we have the angels there's a lot
of angelic presence around here on
planet earth and angels
we need them we need more of them yeah
and so they are um
empathic like but empathic to a fault
which means that they get very
overwhelmed easily they're very they get
very anxious in situations which i don't
blame them
um and they just want to help like these
are the people who will take the shirt
off their back to say hey here you go
like let me assist you let me help you
um they're typically like in positions
of help or support or like services um
like public servants um nurses i've seen
a lot of angels in nursing positions
um
and and even doctors but it's just
there's this like
soft essence soft energy around the
angelic energy and vibration
and they also tend to be very naive
actually so they get taken advantage of
a lot of like as long as i give love out
they'll feel that love and i'll receive
love back
and their whole life they're just
forgiving and forgiving and forgiving
and they keep getting taken advantage of
and it just it yeah it just pains my
soul to like see that happen because it
happens a lot
so those are the angels typically at a
physical level they can kind of look any
sort of way um angels are usually like
like as far as like an angelic like
physical line it would be like more
petite like they're smaller you know
around five to five and a half feet tall
and you just feel their presence oh yeah
they're naturally gifted healers so they
tend to gravitate towards reiki and
energy healing and crystals and all of
that stuff too so the angels are really
nice
um and then we have some of the other
kind of like more dense beings so the
anunnaki are were pretty prevalent on
planet earth and their intermingling
with human beings dates all the way back
to and actually long before
ancient sites like ancient egypt i
remember watching plenty of videos about
them and that they came to this planet
to mine gold
and that they created humans as
essentially slave race so they didn't
have to do it and they were the ones
that invented time and schedules and all
that thing and all that because there
was basically slaves mining this gold
for them because they needed this
element on their planet is that true
a hundred percent it's true yeah so i've
been able to actually remote view into
these ancient human history timelines to
actually take a look at what's going on
so i didn't know that there was all
these people who were going back into
ancient sumerian records to to say oh
well this is what happened and these
were the giants right in quotations um
so i didn't know that there was there
was people saying all the same things
that i was saying because all i know is
what i've channeled and what i've seen
and what i've remote viewed right which
keeps the information for me anyway very
pure and i don't have all this
perception to navigate through other
than my own
um so yeah so the anunnaki originally
created human beings they're actually
considered um
like what are they considered kind of
like the creator species in in this
galaxy anyway so they created up
creating the palladians as well like
they've created a lot of
humanoid-looking
um civilizations and they always
typically create these civilizations for
their own wants and needs and then
whenever they get i don't know they get
what they want or they get bored or
whatever they're like okay peace see ya
and they've just created this
civilization they've just created this
whole entire species and uh and they
walk away from it um
so is that where we came from is that
where we came from then
did we start off as like in what was it
the um trying to think of the stanley
kubrick movie with um
anyway at the very beginning it's
monkeys for like ever it's like a half
an hour monkeys you're like i totally
get it okay
um but did we start off as some was
there an entity on this planet or did we
or were we brought here
from another planet uh there was like
the basically the neanderthals we were
at the point of being a neanderthal okay
um and it probably would have taken
hundreds of millions of billions of
years to get to where we are right now
if we had no intervention
um so i believe that we're a
manufactured species and not a an
organic species um and so the first huge
shift in our evolution the first huge
gap that that science can't explain is
when the anunnaki came to this planet
and what's really fascinating about that
like
immediately when i started to take a
look at the amount of intervention let's
say that happened in our human history
and i was channeling this and and remote
viewing these ancient human history
timelines i was pissed i was so angry
i'm like what
no way like that's not okay like they
they can't just do that now granted we
did evolve so i went to the galactic
federation this is like 10 years ago and
i'm like yo guys come on like you have
all these resources you have all of this
technology and you didn't stop them from
making us slaves for how many years
hundreds of thousands of years like what
and um
they always laugh at me when i get upset
because it's a very human reaction right
like it's like my human coming through
and they explained to me they said we've
been aware of every different um
species civilization being to
manipulate earth or manipulate human
beings whether it be in a physical way
energetic way and they said we only
allow what is contracted to happen
and essentially by saying that they they
implied that everything that took place
with the anunnaki was contracted to
happen because what did they do they
evolved us hundreds of thousands if not
millions of years in a matter of a short
period of time and yeah they taught us
math they taught us astrology uh
astronomy they taught us a sacred uh
geometry you know they like they gave us
art they gave us they gave us a lot of
stuff um
and there was a really interesting point
in the evolution when they were working
with human beings
and
they were they were
they were very hesitant to allow this
like species that they created to evolve
on their own and what i mean by that is
they were very hesitant to allow us to
breed uh with each other so they
actually didn't allow us to have babies
for a very long time so there's like i
think three generations that they worked
with so generation one and generation
two of their hybrid from the
neanderthals they just uh they basically
didn't allow us to procreate
they procreate with us
okay so
uh yes
so
because
they basically wanted population control
because they knew that if they could
control that then they would be always
in charge and so what happened was by
gen 3 they were kind of sick and tied
they didn't have the resources anymore
to create us one by one by hand to kind
of keep the population going so they
then created the next generation which
was we were able to procreate with each
other um the anunnaki ended up falling
in love with the female humans quite
often actually
and um and so they started to procreate
with the female humans this this
you know hybrid species that they
created and they started to create
babies together and in ancient greece
like i also went back into ancient greek
times and they were considered the
demigods right so the anunnaki were
considered the gods and the uh creation
between the gods and the humans were
considered the demigods so they weren't
necessarily 20
30 feet tall they were more so ten feet
tall you know as this kind of pairing so
uh even if how does a woman handle a
20-foot man's thing you know like i
don't get it but you know
i i i
am very curious about that as well um or
maybe not maybe i'm not at all uh
so
so
you know the annunaki are very
interesting like at first i was like wow
like what an evil civilization you know
i really look down upon them but now i
understand that they're just very
actually they're very divine masculine
driven so yeah there are female
annunakis who are all back on their home
planet and only the male honor notties
were allowed here that should say
everything okay is that oh yeah
yeah you know they're just male
dominated and and they they want it
their way
um
but in that way they're just very
logical and analytical and they just
they they get what they need and they
get out and like they're they didn't
really necessarily have like a malice
intent let's say and they still don't
have a malice intent um and there's
actually a ton of anunnaki who work with
the galactic federation uh it might not
be the entire species of the anunnaki
but there's definitely individuals that
work with the gfl and kind of help them
help us um is uh is their planet nibiru
what's their planet yeah their planet is
nibiru and sometimes referred to as
planet x and they have other planets as
well that they have completely inhabited
oh wow and doesn't that come and make a
cycle
like doesn't its orbit
come into our ga and into our orbit
every so often is it 12 000 years or 26
thousand years i can't remember yeah
something like that yeah so a lot of
people um think that the this world is
going to end with planet x because the
the magnitude of how close that planet
is going to come to our planet is going
to be
yeah so a lot of people uh believe that
like major earthquakes and things like
that i don't i don't necessarily believe
that i don't believe that there's much
of uh i believe that there are you know
gravitational pulls and other things in
astrophysics but um i don't necessarily
believe there's some huge significance
behind that planet in particular with us
even though there has been a huge
significance with the annunaki and i
know that there's a lot of like very
strong anunnaki
incarnates here
acting as human beings and typically
the anunnaki incarnates as like a
starseed are
once again very divine masculine
very much so leaders uh very um kind of
very much so in a delegation sort of
role
um and a lot of the anunnaki who have
incarnated as human beings they really
want to see the
the shift to a higher frequency they
want to see that through so they're very
they're very interactive with the
spiritual awakening and and want the the
light to win essentially
it's like they're kind of like overdoing
their wrongs like they want to kind of
reverse the damage that they did in the
past but looking back at it you know i'm
grateful that they intermingled with us
they
advanced us more than any other
civilization out there did and here we
are today it's almost like their earth
existence like their human existence is
sort of like their penance or their
purgatory a hundred percentage because
it's so hard here yeah it's like oh you
know those little funny memes where it's
like you know i thought that i thought
coming to earth to be a lot easier you
know things like that like oh my god why
did i really sign up for this um beam me
up scotty okay i know i got us off on a
really big tangent on the anunnaki but
it's probably one of them that i've
looked into the most so okay so the
anunnaki um we've got the palladians the
octurians
angelics oh and i think you talked about
the octarians before the angelics um
what else do we have here we do have
reptilians here um i think that that's
that's another like hugely
i talked about you know which is i'm
glad that it's hugely talked about
i remember back in the day when i
started to um remote view around planet
earth because you know you step into the
ability of being consciously aware of
like going anywhere you want and so
you're like a kid in a candy store like
oh my god
i'd never come out of my bedroom i had
just been sitting at my altar the whole
time just like
having a ball going all over the
universe so i give you major props for
doing interviews and
yeah i did that for the first couple
years until i kind of got all of my
major questions out of the way but i i
went i ended up going to a lot of like
underground military bases
um i just kind of took a look at the
seedier side of the shadow government
and i started to interact with a lot of
these i called them dinosaur beings
because i didn't know what they were
called right
and
they were just giant like 10 feet tall
uh green scaly looking like a freaking
humanoid dinosaur sometimes they had
tails even
it was bizarre
and like some sort of weird mutation
from like the t-rex you know like that's
kind of what it felt like
and so this is going to be really wild
this is actually even wilder than the
annunaki
um and this is just everything that i've
channeled from looking into human
history this is probably going to be
it's probably already a lot for your
community but
we're going there we're doing it you're
here for it
so
before the annunaki ever came to planet
earth um what i was taking a look at in
human history like long before lymeria
long before atlantis long before these
ancient sumerian civilization
mesopotamia all of it
um there were the dinosaurs and they did
walk the earth and the most intelligent
civilization with the dinosaurs was
these reptilian beings so what i saw is
that the reptilian beings
were originally a part of this planet
and the ecosystem and i don't know how
they got here i don't know if they
were planted here or if they actually
just naturally evolved here i know that
there are tons of reptilian beings and
draco beings and archon beings out there
in the universe but specifically for
this planet
there was this group and it felt like
they naturally evolved and they saved
themselves from one of the huge
cataclysms on planet earth because they
were able to go underground because they
had the intelligence they had the they
had kind of the brain power more so than
the rest of the dinosaurs that were more
so like animals if that makes sense
um
and so
when the annunaki came here the
reptilians told them uh-uh you're not
allowed to be here this is our planet
you can't just come here and think that
you're gonna take over these neanderthal
monkey you know beings like that that's
they you we own them not you and so the
annunaki said
we'll advance you
and we'll work with you
so that when we leave you can be in full
control of the human beings
and so
so the uh so the reptilians were like
sure yeah that works for us
and so they ended up working with the
anunnaki so at a certain point in time
so back in ancient egypt the the
structure the system was the anunnaki
the large giant humanoid beings were
considered the gods of the time and
there's literally
statues that represent how big they
actually were um even hieroglyphs that
have hieroglyphs that represent them
sitting down and the height difference
between them and the humans i mean crazy
um
so there was the anunnaki who were
considered the gods of that time and
then there were the reptilians who were
also walking around during ancient egypt
and they were considered like the way
that i saw it was like they were almost
like the managers of the humans as the
slaves like humans were really truly
still enslaved back then
um
then one of the craziest
like
i guess human history moments that i
ever witnessed it was so cool and this
was many years ago but this was like
many many years ago um as far as
timeline so this was like dead ancient
egypt era
and you know i saw the pyramids they
were already built at that time and
there was these three huge like giant
ships that came down and hovered over
the pyramids of ancient egypt and it
like they were so big and i could tell
because of the shadow that they cast on
the ground right of ancient egypt once
again this is the time where the
anunnaki and the reptilian were in full
control of the humans
so these ships happen to be the galactic
federation ships and the galactic
federation came to ancient egypt and
said
look you have been here for long enough
and it's time that you leave human
beings to their own devices like let
them evolve on their own so this was
kind of a point in time where the
contracts uh with these civilizations
and these beings were ending and it was
time that they they kind of just leave
human beings alone so the gfl came down
and said that
and so the annunaki were like all right
cool we're not going to fight you we're
gone we got what we needed anyway which
is really just mining gold and then they
stayed a little
tiny question just in the middle of this
yeah were the tops of the pyramids made
of gold and did they take them with them
then i didn't see them take them but i
also never asked that question
at that point in time they were like
they were fully made of gold yeah like
they were shining
i just put that together as you were
talking about it in the anunnaki being
there and the tops of the pyramids and
then i thought to myself where are the
because i was in egypt last year and of
course i've but i've studied egypt for a
long time and it's like where are the
tops and
there's obviously the theory that they
were made of gold and so if that was the
annunaki there and they're like got it
we got our stuff like they're like
take the tops yeah okay anyway keep
going didn't even think about that yeah
so the annunaki were gone they were like
okay cool we're leaving we got we wanted
they stayed for longer than they should
have anyway
but the reptilians said to the galactic
federation absolutely not we're not
leaving this is our planet the human
beings have no right to be here they're
the ones that need to be kicked off
and so the galactic federation went to
their councils and they discussed it
amongst themselves and said well they're
not wrong and
i roll because of the law of
non-intervention we actually can't push
them off of their own planet because
they do have a right to it so what the
galactic federation said is okay
we've decided that we'll let you stay
but you cannot be seen by humans
and they thought
you cannot be influenced by humans if
you can't be seen by humans that's what
they thought so that was the contract
that was created back then in ancient
egypt so the anunnaki left found their
ships and they went away and they were
happy and the reptilians went
underground
um just like they did when the
cataclysms happened with the dinosaurs
okay and while they were underground
they said how do we
uh
influence human beings still maintain
control of human beings
uh without being seen and they started
to create technology and they started to
work with the bloodlines and the
bloodlines were picking out certain
individuals who have been um
very similar to the anunnaki mixing with
the humans the reptilians were also
mixing with the humans creating these
hybrids and through those bloodlines
they were able to actually
like basically what they can do is they
can transport their consciousness kind
of like astral traveling and move into
the body of a human being who has higher
than normal reptilian dna and in that
way they can fully take over the body
and fully influence the body under their
will essentially kicking the original
human soul out of the body
along with the technology that they have
to kind of like uh holograph themselves
and that's kind of more recent
technology to holograph themselves to
look like a human um and that's where
they can shape shift out of that human
form
so
since then is when they've been in full
control and it's kind of like a face
palm for the galactic federation to be
like we really should have worded that
contract a different way
however however once again going up
there and getting pissed at them like
guys come on like who did you fire for
this like
somebody's somebody's going down for
this one
um they told me once again it was all a
part of the contracts because
what the reptilians have been doing and
like shape-shifting and pretending to be
humans and
creating wars quote-unquote and like
fear and just distraction and so much
drama really on planet earth
um it is allowing human beings to see
the darkest aspects of ourselves and the
darkest aspects of the universe and i
really believe that the reptilian beings
um and also all the dark energy on
planet earth is kind of sticking their
their foot in their mouth because uh by
pushing so much fear and so much
darkness at a certain point in time
humans are going to be like
yeah you know what i'm just not gonna
watch the news anymore because i have an
anxiety attack every time i do
like literally there's so much darkness
that they're turning to the light on
their own free will and volition because
they're just sick and tired of being
sick and tired and i get that and and
2020 to now is really showing us that we
can make a higher vibrational choice
so i'm really fascinated with the
bloodlines i just i'm that's another
another area of curiosity okay bloodline
was jesus okay so jesus i believe his
soul was an ascended master
and the bloodline of the body um
was very palladian so
he's he kind of had that mix of both and
then of course his teachings got
extremely skewed uh further down the
line um the one time i connected with
jesus as an ascended master just in my
meditation i didn't expect it
and
you know his purpose
to to bring to planet earth to incarnate
here was to
um embody absolute unconditional love
and with that embodiment and
unconditional love isn't like i love
i love you unconditionally it's not that
romanticized [ __ ] honestly it's a
vibrational frequency that is of the
highest vibration
and
in that frequency that's where you can
turn water into wine that's where you
can create fish out of nothing that's
where you can walk on water because he
was essentially defying the laws of
physics while he was around
simply because he was in a hot much much
higher vibration
and i believe and what he was trying to
teach us all is that we can all embody
that vibration and we can all defies
defy the laws of physics classical
physics like
for example if i wanted to stick my hand
through this wall i could in this uh
highest vibration you know and i believe
that that's possible so that's kind of
what he was here to show us all
okay okay so with the bloodlines is
there i've heard that there's
a pretty big mission to get rid of
certain bloodlines no i haven't i
haven't heard that but obviously like i
don't i don't hear everything i don't
know everything but what i know is that
the bloodlines that have had okay
there's two bloodlines that have the
most emphasis the highest vibrational
bloodlines and the lowest vibrational
about bloodlines um the highest
vibrational ones are typically like
prone to getting psychically attacked
their entire lives since they were born
so whether that be really bad nightmares
or just really bad luck or you know
never really being able to get ahead or
just having freak accidents you know
that can be caused by just being a light
worker just being here in the highest
vibration and and that light causes
those shadows i always say the brighter
the light you shine the darker shadow
you cast getting to the unconditional
love part it's like i understand the
darkest aspects of myself and i love the
darkest aspects of myself and i
understand the brightest aspects and i
love those too you know it's loving both
sides in unity um and then the lowest
vibrational um bloodlines are mostly
just the reptilian bloodlines and they
are
obsessed with
uh keeping those bloodlines a certain
way that's why there's a lot of
interbreeding when it comes to and when
we witness the
royal bloodlines that's why there's a
lot of like oh go ahead and marry your
cousin because he's the duke of whatever
it's not that they wanted to keep the
money or the power it's that they wanted
to keep the bloodlines um so that the
reptilians can continue to come in and
apparently one of the most witnessed
shape shifter
uh
in present day is queen elizabeth and
there are like what i've read as far as
like um
blogs and articles and and different
things from england is
uh there are thousands of calls every
single year for every appearance that
she makes of like oh my god like i don't
am i losing my mind do i need to go
visit a hospital but like i swear i just
saw queen elizabeth as like a 10 foot
tall uh lizard you know what i mean like
these are just people who are just out
there waving the flag watching queenie
just walking by and they literally see
her in her true form
which i think is really fascinating
what other
people in power whether they're you know
some of them obviously queen elizabeth
or maybe some people in government but
even if there are some others like who
are who are some shape-shifter who are
some reptilian
um
beings
that we know about
or that you know about justin bieber
bieber adele um jay-z has been like
known to to shape-shift in front of
people
um kanye west for sure uh
you know and it's it's really sad
because these these celebrities these
politicians from a very young age they
go through a very similar indoctrination
process to say something called mk-ultra
which is a complete brainwashing and
what they do is they disassociate the
soul from the body and that's why a lot
of these celebrities have disassociative
identity disorder um different
personalities they have moods things
they have absolute collapses when
they're in their 20s because they've
gone through so much trauma so you
really have to feel
compassion to these these individuals at
a human level
maybe before the transition so you know
i don't want to say that every
politician every celebrity um it's it's
uh there are some very prominent ones
out there like um
you know even angelina jolie i ended up
seeing a video that was like super
underground of her talking about like
killing small animals and blood and sex
rituals
in order to be kind of in order to
maintain her status in this community
right way in the illuminati or whatever
you want to call it but you know these
things do exist and
it's really important that we understand
what's out there and we understand
what's happening but it's simultaneously
that much more important to understand
that that is one small piece of the
greater picture that's taking place on
planet earth and we're actually getting
away from all of that shadowy government
illuminati reptilian shape-shifter stuff
and we're moving into a much higher
vibration because i know for me i was so
obsessed with shape shifters and dark
agendas and shadow governments and
illuminati and seeing all of the signs
that
it really put me into a low vibrational
place i call it a 4d place for a number
of years before i'm like well what more
is there you know what else is going on
in the universe and that's why i'm like
oh there's this whole galactic
federation full of beings who are here
to help us ascend and get to a higher
frequency it's really important that we
understand what's out there and we
understand what's happening but it's
simultaneously that much more important
to understand that that is one small
piece of the greater picture that's
taking place on planet earth and we're
actually getting away from all of that
shadowy government illuminati reptilian
shape-shifter stuff and we're moving
into a much higher vibration because i
know for me i was so obsessed with
shapeshifters and dark agendas and
shadow governments and illuminati and
seeing all of the signs that
it really put me into a low vibrational
place
i call it a 4d place for a number of
years before i'm like well what more is
there you know what else is going on in
the universe and that's why i'm like oh
there's this whole galactic federation
full of beings who are here to help us
ascend and get to a higher frequency
yeah
um well let's talk about that let's talk
about
i mean i feel like maybe the starting
point is reincarnation it's the you know
us as souls and i know that past life
regression was something that your dad
did for you and that you
started doing yourself um soon after um
so maybe with that like what you know
explain reincarnation explain how we
come into this body
in this
point in time in this family with all
these things like how does this whole
process work from death to rebirth
all right we got five hours so yeah
i'll uh i'll sum it up so yeah so my
kind of beginning uh
consciously to get into all of this
stuff
was was past life regression
and
okay so
i'll bring it like super macro and then
i'll bring it super micro so at a macro
level like in the entire universe you've
got source frequency source energy some
people call it god i just call it source
um
and source is unity it's all it's
everything and nothing it's light and
dark and source decided to
split itself off many times over and
incarnate into
singular versions of itself so if it's
all the colors in the rainbow it's like
i'm just going to be red for this
lifetime i'm just going to be yellow and
the reason why source decided to go back
to the beginning go back to the
nothingness is because they wanted to
learn it wanted to experience it wanted
to grow
and that's kind of where
we come into play and plants and animals
and all of that have a piece of source
have that soul
we're all experiencing different lessons
so the whole point of life in general
getting away from all the conspiracies
and the agendas is really just to be
here to learn to experience to grow to
get challenged to move forward there's a
really pivotal conversation that i had
with source itself many years ago and
the question i asked is like
you know i get asked this question all
the time why is there so much suffering
like why if you're this almighty all
knowing all omnipresent thing why would
you allow that and source came back to
me to say
okay imagine you had access to
everything in my 3d world all material
possessions all friends all great
dynamics all knowledge all information
all anything you could ever possibly
imagine you had it all
and source said
all right elizabeth how long would it
take for you to get bored
i'm like
yeah not long if you have it all where
do you go from there and so source
decided to kind of reverse itself and to
split itself off and so if you imagine
like i believe there are 12 dimensions
in this universe and of course there are
many different universes
and every dimension has a certain
vibrational frequency to it the lower
dimensions are further away from source
further away from infinity or
unconditional love frequency so they're
more singular they're more linear and
then the closer you are to source and
the higher dimensions the more a part of
source you become um in that way and so
if you could imagine like just in a very
plain way every dimension there's a
thousand lessons that you have to learn
in that said dimension you incarnate a
thousand times or sometimes it takes ten
thousand incarnations to learn the
thoughts i know those people or what
have you
um you learn what you need to from that
dimension and you move on to the next
one now i originally thought upon
receiving that information okay
dimension one dimension two dimension
three dimension four
my linear mind perceived it as that then
i started doing past life regression for
people and i'm like
you were an 11th dimensional angel in
your past life like in your very last
lifetime what are you doing as a third
dimensional human and i started to
realize that it doesn't go one two three
four five it goes you go wherever you
need you are needed to experience that
lesson
um
yeah so there is a difference in souls
on this planet at this time which is
super unprecedented and very very very
unlike any other third dimensional uh
terrestrial planet out there typically
third dimensional planets have third
dimensional souls period like that's
even though it doesn't have to be that
way that's typically the way if you're
presented in a reality that contains
this much or a certain amount of energy
your soul is going to match that much
energy it's like fitting a you know a
round peg into a round hole that's
essentially what it is um this planet is
obviously different there's a huge shift
that's taking place we're this massive
peace treaty so we have
bad influences we've got these shape
shifters we've got these dark entities
and however we also have all of these
other beings who are choosing to be here
at this time
so the galactic federation said all
right we kind of messed up you know the
reptilian beings are on planet earth
they're manipulating human beings what
can we do to help and they went through
a lot of different things to try and
help humans i'll name two of their
attempts and then i'll name the third
one which is actually what the success
was the first thing that they really
tried was
let's just go
greet the humans in our true form and
tell them that there's so much more than
this and that they're so powerful that
they can do it you know and all of a
sudden they're like
an angel from the sky came to greet me
let's write a bible about it i must
indoctrinate more people you know into
this limited frame of belief um or they
were deemed crazy and unfortunately they
got persecuted for having these
experiences or they became some sort of
religious leader and totally took it out
of context so that strategy did not work
um the second strategy that they uh
tried and they've tried many these are
just a couple
is they're like
let's go ahead and manufacture a
vibrational grid around the planet that
every human being is connected to so
it's kind of like a mini it's almost
like we have our mini sun or a mini
source but it's kind of like a grid all
around planet earth and that helps me
connect to you even without words you
know all across the planet and there's
actually been a couple of different
really cool studies that show that we
are connected in an unspoken way
um so they manufactured that and that
helped to a certain extent uh and we
still have this consciousness grid
around planet earth today which is
getting more and more activated which is
really cool
um there
the other thing that they tried that
really started to work is they're like
okay
if the humans won't
listen to us
or they do listen to us and they
misinterpret us because we're so
different because we can fly and float
and we come down in ships or we look
different or what have you
let's just go ahead and be the human
maybe they'll listen to their own kind
wink wing nudge nudge yes that didn't go
over so well so that's when the galactic
federation started to look for
volunteers
hey beautiful beings of higher
frequencies do you want to go on an
adventure of a lifetime
it's gonna be really fun you know and so
like a roller coaster yeah
the ups and the downs like just imagine
jail you know
[Laughter]
but that's you know and it was really
tough to find volunteers from the
galactic federation as you could imagine
why would we leave all of this and go
down there
you know but that's what they needed
they needed
they needed individuals who had a higher
natural vibration to come to planet
earth to teach the humans while being a
human
and this started to work like this
technique was the first one to really
make a huge impact um and that's kind of
how
uh you know star seeds got born and so i
always say star seeds and when i
reference star seeds it means that your
soul is not originally
from the lower dimensions it's not
originally from planet earth it's
actually from much higher dimensions and
you came to incarnate and volunteered to
be here as a human the problem that
happened what percentage of people are
volunteers then
um
it starts increasing it's been
increasing i would say at this point in
time
around
i don't know it's hard to say i would
say between 10 to 20 percent got it okay
which is actually a huge number of
people yeah it is you know
and so and i think it's the numbers are
increasing and more more starseeds are
increasing here
so this is what maybe dolores cannon was
speaking about about the three waves of
volunteers right and they kind of have
their own sort of end sort of
characteristics but there's been three
waves of volunteers in the most recent
are really the crystal children that
already have the upgraded dna that you
know are growing up right now
absolutely yeah okay totally
okay and and you know it's
it's so fascinating to meet a being
who's never been to this planet before
and they're just so bewildered and
excited and sometimes super apathetic
and they're just like they're so over
stimulated they're so overwhelmed with
everything that's taking place that they
don't know uh they don't know where to
go right and like so i call it a
a starseed a syndrome starseen syndrome
is basically where they're just floating
along life they they don't really have
any passions because it's just too
overwhelming for them to be here and
this is where we get into imprinted
lifetimes which i believe is the new
uh the new 5d version of
volunteers coming to planet earth is
why would you want to live out all of
these dense human lifetimes of suffering
and challenge and the middle ages which
were awful um when you could just
download all of those lifetimes it's
kind of like reading a book and saying
all right i've read the the how to human
guide for planet earth because i've
downloaded and imprinted all of these
past lives and now i've got enough
skills to come to planet earth with and
me as a past life regressionist
especially at the beginning of my career
um it was very difficult to tell the
difference between what lifetimes are
imprinted and what lifetimes are real
and there's a whole few like flurry of
issues uh when we're getting into that
because if you get a random flashback of
a past life of you getting persecuted
and you believe that you really lived in
that lifetime then just by believing
that was truly you you could create
karma around that the whole point of
past life imprinting is of course you
get to hop over the space and the time
of actually living through the lifetime
but you also come to the planet with
zero karma because you took zero of that
action in those lifetimes that you're
imprinting you come with a very clean
energy center
what what what would you tell people if
they were gonna
but let's say someone was about to lose
someone what does that mean oh lose
someone
like what happens then
yeah always come back is that you always
come back as a human
or you don't always right you go other
places but you don't
die essentially your energy doesn't die
yeah no definitely not so i do like i
used to do with clients a lot of um
one-on-one work and a lot of mediumship
uh and so i would actually follow the
soul through the white light tunnel so
that's not all a thing like you you hear
a lot about um like near-death
experiences and it's all very similar to
that when you
pass away
um you have a choice to make and do i
have unfinished business and do i stick
around or do i move on and when a soul
decides to stick around but their body
ends up passing away
then they're kind of in this weird lemon
liminal realm so the way that i see it
because i kind of go to them is it's
kind of like they're just in a dark room
and they're full of emotions and they're
full of fears and they're full of
attachments and what happened and what
if and i should have and why not and all
of these regrets and because of that
emotion that's unresolved or the
attachment that's unresolved they end up
getting stuck there and we can interpret
or see them as like a ghost like they're
a spirit and and the dark room that
they're in could be the house that they
passed away in and then they're attached
to that house and they don't really know
that they're attached and they don't
know that there's another way
so
that's when i can come in and say hey
you know
like let me hear your story what do you
what information do you need to get out
in order to feel like your soul is
relieved enough to cross over then i'll
go ahead and cross them over some
individuals have such a light-hearted
energy they're like i know that i've
been you know slowly
decaying for a while and i'm prepared
for death and when their body um passes
away their soul goes right into the
light and they end up crossing over and
that's why their friends and family
members and spirit guides and everyone
is there to greet them and it's huge
celebration and all of their heaviness
and fears and regret from the past in
this lifetime go away instantly and then
there's a period in time some souls take
longer than others where they have to
review their lifetime it's like the
lifetime review yeah it's like these are
the decisions that you made and these
are the people that you impacted and and
so i don't believe that there's a heaven
and a health like in a religious sense
but i do believe that there's
higher and lower vibrations that you can
experience afterwards eventually a soul
will choose to cross over they're not
stuck there indefinitely they will when
they're ready when they're ready they
will cross over to the light and then in
that place after you've reviewed your
lifetime and you figured out what body
do i want to be in next what incarnation
do i want to experience what challenges
have i yet to experience
and then you get uh put into the
incarnation that best serves your
highest vibrational good sometimes
you're a tree like people don't realize
that we can be a tree we can be an ant
we can be a bird you know in the sky um
and so
yeah
wow
so what is what do we have with us on
earth as far as guides and
energies around us do we always have
like a dedicated certain
certain kinds of people around us that
are just dedicated to us i i guess i
understand that you could connect with
connect with
anyone in the galactic federation or
them themselves and entities but do we
have
certain angels or guides or like what is
around us on this in this world
yeah so on average i've observed that
people have about 10 spirit guides
some of their spirit guides are humans
from this lifetime from past lifetimes
from their ancestral lineage and some of
those spirit guides are interdimensional
or extraterrestrial beings whether they
be angels or you know
grays or the like um and then so the
spirit guides actually come and go all
the time so our kind of sometimes we
have set spirit guides for our entire
life but most likely what i've seen is
that we have a spirit guide maybe for 10
years and they're there with us for the
specific energy that they need to give
us at that time and even when we think
about interdimensional spirit guides
they are typically beings that you've
lived with uh on different planets in
different dimensions um as well so
they're kind of like family for you and
they volunteer for that position so
no one in your spirit guide group is
just random
you know you know everyone like family
and so i could always tell who was
a volunteer starseed versus a human
based on how many humans or how many
star seeds or interdimensionals they had
in their spirit guide group so i always
thought that that was a really
interesting way of telling you know who
that soul is because if you have a bunch
of aliens in your group it's like well
you're one of them and you really need
their guidance because this is a tough
terrain to navigate um whereas if you
have a lot of humans like they're here
to help you with the human experience
and it's always good to have five and
five you know to have a good mix um one
being that will always stay with you
i believe for your entire incarnation if
not every
incarnation you've ever had or ever will
have is your guardian angel and they're
a really set fixture in your energy and
vibration and um they're kind of the
frequency of your higher self and i just
want to mention that spirit guides are
never there to tell you what to do okay
spirit guides are only there to help you
align to your highest vibrational
contracts all right so they never
they're never allowed to just disempower
you or uh make decisions for you they're
just there to guide you
how do we ask do we have to ask them for
help
uh yeah if you if i mean they're there
to help you and kind of give you those
signs and those red flags or whatever
throughout our way but if you really
want to be clear or you have a very
specific situation that you need
assistance on absolutely find a quiet
place um let go of your your mind and
your thoughts and connect with them by
saying i want to connect my spirit
guides for the highest good of all
involved and this is what i really need
help with
so many people believe that they are not
psychic because they do not hear their
spirit guides talking back to them we
need to realize that our spirit guides
come into our physical realities in many
different ways sometimes you'll just be
browsing on google and a weird random
video will pop up or an article will pop
up that's actually messages from them
all right so weird random moments
incidents even accidents uh just random
things can come into our lives where
you're walking by a stranger and they're
talking on the phone and they're talking
about the exact situation that you're in
and you get the piece of information
that you need at that time that's your
spirit guides got it got it so are there
old souls then or souls that are more if
have come through more incarnations more
lifetimes more experiences than others
yeah for sure it's uh kind of irrelevant
to say old because it implies that
you've been around for longer and the
amount of time that you've been around
is actually irrelevant because it's the
amount of experience that you've gained
access to like one of my clients in the
past and i don't i don't do any more
one-on-one sessions so i have to put
that out there um
but one of my clients in the past she
was learning the lesson of grief and
grieving which granted is a really tough
life lesson to learn but what that means
is
everyone she's ever loved every animal
she's ever had have all passed away way
before their time in super horrific ways
right so she's experienced a ton of
grief in this lifetime when i took a
look at her past life records um in the
akashic records i saw that this is her
10th lifetime learning the same lesson
one lesson 10 entire lifetimes which
could potentially be a very long time
whereas you know some people will go
through one one lifetime learn two
lessons right so the amount of time
doesn't necessarily matter it's the
amount of experience and the willingness
to change that you have
the more stuck you are the more attached
you are the more you identify with
certain elements of your reality the
less willing you are to change i believe
that the number one tool that anyone
needs no matter where you fall on the
spectrum in order to get to a higher
vibration or the fifth dimension
frequency is
the willingness to change if you're
willing to drop everything that you are
right now in this moment or everything
that you have in this moment for
something that's more aligned or in a
higher vibration then you are well on
your way to entering into a higher state
of frequency and you're accepting the
changing and the movement of energy from
moment to moment rather than this is who
i am this is what i have to have every
day this is my schedule this is my
routine and you really lock yourself
into a reality that probably doesn't
serve you or at least maybe it did serve
you and it doesn't anymore
yeah yeah yeah well said thank you for
saying that um
well let's talk about timelines
um as we're kind of winding down on our
own timeline i mean i've been saying for
a couple of years now everything seems
so fast like i can't even
you know if somebody says oh this is
going to take a while like or you know
we'll be working on this and
whatever kind of general just
conversational timeline people give me i
know to not think of it in the same way
that i used to it doesn't mean that the
old sort of maybe parameters for like oh
it's going to take a while be like a few
months it's like this could be next week
like i i who knows right and so
why is that happening
yeah that's a great question and uh they
actually did a survey of people
um through 2020 to 2021
and 50
of people
um all said that time was moving faster
and 50 percent of people all said the
time was moving slower but pretty much
90 percent to 100 of people all said
time worked differently right which is
so fascinating and i feel like once
again when we're removed from routine
and we're just in complete energetic
flow um time does move differently some
days feel really quickly and some days
feel like it was a month long and so
we're starting to experience this kind
of quantumness um of this new frequency
reality and it's like
everything's going to be different but
at such a subtle level that you really
have to be aware of the subtleties to
pick up on it so i'm just gonna plant a
seed and absolutely blow your mind with
what i believe is possible in this new
frequency
so
two years ago i downloaded this um
hypothesis let's say okay scientific
experiment i call it quantum convergence
theory okay so what i believe we are
going to be able to do in our lifetime
at some point and it's going to take
practice is
within a 20 minute period i believe we
will be able to do multiple different
things uh at the same time in the
physical third dimension reality okay so
in 20 minutes it uh it takes you 20
minutes to water all your plants it
takes you 20 minutes to answer all your
emails it takes you 20 minutes to walk
the dog and i believe that in in this
quantum convergence theory i could
actually be sitting on my chair
closing my eyes
uh in a meditative state
and after 20 minutes goes by i open my
eyes the plants are watered the dog is
walked and the emails are sent and
what's happening
you know and so what's happening is all
these timelines are actually converging
together this is where we're getting a
lot of weird timeline glitches but also
a lot of weird glitches in the matrix i
swear i sent that email i remember
saying that email i remember downloading
that form that i needed to send with the
email i have the form i can't find the
email anywhere and the person is telling
me that that never happened and this is
going to ramp up
and the reason why is because
every single time you set an intention
every single time you want to manifest
something uh you hop into a timeline
before that happens if you are
indecisive in life you're hopping into
this timeline then this timeline then
this timeline then this timeline there's
bound to be some sort of timeline glitch
which means that we could set an
intention to walk down one timeline and
end up with the end result of a
different timeline that actually never
supposedly happened this is where we get
into the mandela effect right and these
crazy
glitches that happen
so time is weird timelines are weird and
i believe that at a certain point in
time based on the double slit experiment
um based on uh wave particle duality
we're going to be able to get to a place
where we can do multiple things um at
the exact same time
wow how long do you think that's gonna
take
uh like i said it's gonna take a lot of
practice i think eventually kids will
just be born being able to do this you
know um but i wanna actually uh leave
off with a really good example of this
this timeline thing um so many years ago
i was really
understanding quantum physics and what's
possible within that realm
and i had a friend of mine
call me up and she says
hey you know something really weird took
place and i said what what happened and
she's like well last night you know me
and my husband for the first time ever
had this incredible conversation we
talked for four hours i did a ton of
meditating that day so i was in a higher
vibration and like it was like the first
time we've ever been in 5d together we
hashed everything out it was absolutely
incredible and then we went to bed that
night and she said in the next morning
we both wake up we go to the grocery
store together and on the way
on the drive to the grocery store she
turns to him and says hey what an
incredible conversation we had last
night
and he looks at her and he's like
what do you mean i just watched football
and she's like no no like the you know
four hour conversation i mean we're up
till like one a.m like having this
buddy i mean i went to bed at 10 after
watching the football game and and then
you watched your thing and we went to
bed and she's like am i going crazy like
what's happening and i had to to tap
into it because i'm like i don't know
like that does sound wild
and what i channeled was that
in that moment at
that night
they aligned to the same vibration now
even though she's usually in a different
vibration higher vibration and he's in a
lower vibration she will always lower
herself to be in his vibration whatever
that may be or may look like and that
night he was able to come into her
higher vibration the fifth dimension
frequency in this other timeline
so with quantum physics and
schrodinger's cat and all of those cool
experiments technically both the 3d
timeline where they both watch tv in
different rooms and they laughed about
differently existed at the same time
where they had this four hour
conversation they both simultaneously
existed and then what happened was when
they went to bed that night and they
woke up they woke up in their timelines
their set timelines she woke up in the
fifth dimension frequency he woke up in
the third dimension therefore in her
reality in her memory in her past that
conversation absolutely did take place
because she remembers that timeline
however in his reality in the third
dimension reality the other 3d timeline
took place and that happened
wow
yeah well that supports your theory
yeah
you know it's an example of it of
something like it for sure yeah wow wow
well i guess
i guess if um we're talking about fast
timelines it's like well what would you
recommend with this sort of way that
things are going
what is the best way to take advantage
of time not working
the same
right now on the planet is like a really
pivotal time to manifest especially if
you're listening to this and you've
stayed this long this is a really great
tip so
the majority of the world right now is
in chaos frequency that's what i call it
basically a fear-based frequency and in
a fear-based frequency they are
triggered into fight-or-flight or
survival tendencies which means that
they are not uh consciously creating
their reality which means you do not
have to cut through everyone else's
attempt to create their own reality to
create your own so the playing field
right now in order to manifest is super
clear everyone's in their chaos
frequency and that means that the second
you are clear and intentional about
something it will happen and it will
happen rapid pace things that used to
take years to manifest are taking weeks
if not days if not moments to manifest
so what i would recommend right now for
people is be very intentional and
manifest every single moment of your day
and it's not sitting down to do this
whole manifestation ceremony and vision
board and you don't have to do all of
that anymore it's rapid time so all you
have to do is say
wake up in the morning and have the
routine of what do i want out of my day
today what do i want my day to feel like
by the end of this day
and so that intention will align the
right timeline to that intention if you
are not intentional anything and the
kitchen sink is going to happen that day
why because you were not set on what you
wanted to manifest and create for that
day now one more thing i want to mention
about manifestation
it's very important just like talking to
your spirit guides that you do not
expect or attach yourself to what you
want to manifest um so you know put put
intentions out there without uh
expectation or attachment because
that'll lower the vibration which
essentially does not allow those things
to manifest and
be very aware of how the manifestation
enters into your reality take note of
that so the best example that i have i
was working with manifestation many
years ago every week i was manifesting
something new just to play around with
the energy of it and so the one week i
was like i'm gonna manifest myself a
free cup of coffee um and i knew that a
free cup of coffee was a dollar thirteen
whatever at tim horton's because i'm
canadian and uh
and so i go into uh like a coffee shop
that week and i'm standing in line and
this like super nice like older man like
in front of me starts up this
conversation and i'm thinking this is it
this is my free cup of coffee i've
manifested what i wanted and as we
progress through the line where
we're chatting getting along and then he
goes up to order his cup of coffee and
i'm like okay cool like no big deal i'll
just buy my coffee
so i bought my cup of coffee i walk out
of the the coffee shop and oddly enough
there's a little pile of change on the
ground and now typically i wouldn't kind
of notice it or take note of it or even
pick it up but i felt intuitively
inclined to bend down and pick up the
change and as i'm picking up these dimes
and nickels and quarters and pennies and
whatever i'm counting it and as i come
to that i'm like
it is exactly a dollar thirteen it is
exactly what my cup of coffee was and
in my mind it was it was that
realization of i expected the
manifestation to come in one way and it
came in a completely different way i
still got a free cup of coffee but not
necessarily the way that i expected so
set intentions manifest what you want
but let go of the attachment let go of
the expectation let go of the when and
the how and the where and just trust
yeah yeah
yeah
love that that's a great way to end it
that's so great thank you so much what
what just amazing info and i'm sure
we're blowing some minds especially if
they've hung on to the end but if
they've hung on to the end they're
probably into this anyway so um thank
you so much thank you for sharing and
you know i definitely think people
should start following you and follow
your updates it's good stuff i love it
thank you
yeah absolutely thank you so much for
having me on and um
if anyone does want to follow up like
there's tons of information out there so
it's just elizabethan.com or elizabeth
april kind of everywhere um on all
socials so that's kind of it's going to
be your deep dive for for the follow
through of this content but we covered a
ton of topics today i'm super impressed
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the subscribe button